bonsoir ça va bien ça va Eden ça va très
bien alors on va voir ce que vous avez
fait en tout cas c'est vrai que il y a
quelque chose franchement je suis désolé
tu vois toi direct quelqu'un qui vient
de se faire Ken
on est bien
avec nous comment ça va mon ciné ça va
bien tu es bronzé tu es bien chirurgien
esthétique bien sûr de renom si tu vas
nous dire ce que tu penses de cette
pratique parce que c'est vrai que c'est
un truc de fou le Barbie Botox qu'est-ce
que c'est que le barbu Botox
c'est l'utilisation du Botox pour
essayer de ressembler à Barbie donc
c'est simple les particularités de
Barbie c'est qu'elle a un Coulon et
qu'elle a une façon de tenir sa tête
très droite
le Botox
je suis en Barbie là et donc le Botox
dans l'esprit de beaucoup de gens a
mauvaise réputation on croit que sa
fille etc l'image que tout le monde a
non mais c'est vrai parce que c'est bien
qu'on fasse une petite parenthèse
là-dessus sur le Botox ça fiche moi je
vois des mecs et qui ont fait du Botox
ils peuvent plus froncer le front ils
ont le front en fait ils sont ils sont
toujours comme ça quoi c'est comme toute
technique il y a une part artistique et
pour cela il faut bien doser d'accord
10e de
100e du Nissan c'est très dur ce qu'on
doit le faire par rapport aux muscles de
chacun d'accord mais le Botox il faut
pas pénaliser dans notre imaginaire
parce que le Botox pour noter les
spectateurs le Botox c'est un produit
qu'on utilise depuis des dizaines
d'années qui ont des services énormes un
enfant qui n'est avec un pied spastique
pour le redresser on utilise le Botox un
enfant un nourrisson
un torticolis très douloureux on utilise
le Bostock il paraît difficile avec un
épices facial on utilise le Botox
comment agile Botox il endort le muscle
il empêche le muscle de se contracter
donc ça rend des services même à
d'autres endroits du corps donc c'est un
très bon produit sauf comme dans tout
quand il est détourné pour deux
utilisations pour lesquelles il n'a pas
ce qu'on appelle la MM l'autorisation de
mise sur le marché
dont on va parler il n'a pas
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché ni
l'autorisation aux États-Unis de la FDA
alors donc le barbibotox c'est allonger
le coup de la patiente et affiner ses
épaules vous l'avez fait vous Eden
alors il y a plusieurs raisons
premièrement et je le déplore c'est que
j'étais influencée par mon écosystème
mon métier qui est le mannequinat parce
que
nous dans le matin très avant-gardiste
par rapport à ce baril Botox que nous on
a appelé trap tox à l'époque
et donc oui j'étais influencée par par
des mannequins des mondes en fait et
donc moi je l'ai fait il y a quelques
mois déjà c'était avant le film c'était
avant le film exactement c'était avant
le film
parce que dans le monde du mannequinat
ça existe déjà et par la suite donc j'ai
vu le film j'ai vu le film Barbie et
c'est vrai que
et je le déplore encore une fois j'étais
influencé par ce film par toutes ces
influences qui font la promotion de
cette chirurgie
malheureusement et
du coup j'ai fait une retouche il y a
quelques jours pourquoi
parce que j'étais influencée j'étais mal
influencée j'ai vu le film je me suis
dit il y a encore il faut faire
on rentre dans une sorte de cercle
une spirale voilà perfectionniste où on
veut toujours être plus mais vous voulez
ressembler à Barbie vous en fait moi
alors moi j'aime alors on me dit souvent
ça mais moi j'ai pas envie de ressembler
à Barbie parce que j'ai pas envie qu'on
me voit comme une comme une adolescente
qui veut ressembler à Barbie qu'elle
Valérie benaimé
en fait alors on va voir le avant après
chez quelqu'un voilà s'il vous plaît
merci si vous pouvez le mettre merci ils
sont partis en régie non voilà donc
avant après voilà vous voyez voilà vous
voyez et donc ça comment on fait ça
parce qu'on a l'impression qu'on a
maigri en fait alors il y a un muscle
qui s'insère ici dans le dos qui
s'appelle le trapèze ça trapèze et ce
muscle lorsqu'il est un torticolis on
travaillait sur ce muscle et on s'est
rendu compte que ça affiné le muscle et
que ça permettait de d'avoir un effet
optique d'allongement du coup ce qui
fait que ça a été détourné d'accord moi
je voudrais revenir sur quelque chose
qui m'avait surpris dans mon parcours
lorsqu'il y a eu le film Star Trek le
Seigneur des Anneaux je me souviens de
deux ou trois jeunes qui sont devenus
demander
[Musique]
un film avec Rocco Siffredi
je t'ai rien demandé
ça prouve la force du cinéma d'Hollywood
mais à l'époque il y avait pas le relais
des influences kim Kardashian a parlé de
cette technique dans une épisode de
téléréalité les gens ont commencé à
s'intéresser puis les influenceuses en
communiqué là-dessus et ce sont gouffrer
dans ce système un certain nombre de
personnes non des médecins qu'on soit
bien clair c'est interdit aux médecins
de le faire c'est quoi ça ça c'est
interdit
à force d'injecter le muscle s'atrophie
et un moment on pourra plus lever les
bras on aura du mal à tenir la tête
musculaire et c'est donc dangereux il y
a un principe général dans toute la
médecine il doit y avoir une comparaison
entre les bénéfices et les risques donc
si le bénéfice est inférieur aux risques
il faut pas le faire donc il est pas
autorisé pour une indication de redresse
éthique pour un torticolis
en France c'est interdit en France c'est
interdit
et je l'ai fait en France ah d'accord tu
le dis pas parce que tu étais au courant
des dangers qu'il y avait de faire ça
avant de le faire au début justement au
début non j'étais pas au courant des
dangers malheureusement j'ai je pense
que c'est aussi la bêtise de notre
génération en fait de ne pas
j'ai 24 ans
c'est la bêtise de la génération de ne
pas se renseigner en fait sur les
risques des choses c'est aussi aux
praticiens de te le dire avant oui bien
sûr
mais en fait je en fait la chirurgie
parce que moi j'ai pas fait que ça c'est
1000 euros exactement
j'ai fait des implants mammaires donc
les Mamers
[Rires]
et j'ai fait j'ai fait quelques
injections de Botox dans le front la
bouche non pas la bouche c'est le même
principe
la personne qui vous a fait ça pardon
Cyril la personne qui vous a fait ça
elle vous a rien dit elle vous a pas dit
attention il y a ce risque là
et c'est une personne
c'est pas des médecins qui font ça aux
instituts de beauté le conseil de
l'heure des médecins les pourchas il y
en a quelques-unes d'influenceuses dont
vous avez entendu parler qui commence à
passer en justice mais c'est détourné
puisque nous on peut pas le faire et
qu'il y a une demande le danger c'est
qu'il y a une demande et que cette
demande elle vient de jeunes qui n'ont
pas encore un psychisme assez bien
construit et seul un médecin chirurgien
pourrait leur dire non c'est dangereux
voilà les risques ne le faites pas mais
quand elles écoutent Tic-Toc j'ai
interdit Tik Tok depuis cela mes enfants
mes petits-enfants parce que je me dis
si elles sont influencés par cela mais
moi je vais paraître un gars
etc c'est juste que dans notre société
en fait on cherche la perfection mais
mais vous vous êtes vous êtes déjà très
jolie qu'est-ce que vous cherchez en
plus en fait est-ce que ça vous a changé
la vie là de faire le coup et les parce
que là vous avez allongé votre coup oui
j'allonger beaucoup et ça vous quand
vous êtes vus vous êtes dit je suis
content du résultat que j'ai vraiment
changé en fait moi je suis jamais
contente
est-ce que vous êtes content de votre
physique là
qu'est-ce que vous allez refaire
qu'est-ce que vous allez refaire là je
vais faire un refaire parce que je pense
que je vais quand même m'arrêter là
parce que si vous est-ce que vous avez
voilà ce que vous avez dit qu'est-ce qui
n'est pas parfait pour vous chez vous
je sais pas enfin je n'arrive pas à
définir la perfection et je pense que
c'est le problème de la société on
n'arrive pas à votre fiancé il ressemble
à Ken
la dysmorphobie donc exactement c'est ce
dont j'allais parler en fait je suis
victime de ça
le fait de ne pas se voir tel que l'on
est vraiment moi je crois que c'est ce
qui m'arrive mais dans l'autre sens
[Applaudissements]
je me vois beaucoup plus frais que ce
que je ne suis
c'est quoi ça s'appelle la mégalomane
[Musique]
s'il te plaît on parle s'il te plaît
donc Eden est-ce que tu es contente du
résultat
parce que parce que comme je préfère
maintenant ou avant alors je préfère
maintenant d'accord je préfère quand
même maintenant mais c'est vrai que la
dysphorie c'est un la dispo phobie c'est
un vrai problème de notre société c'est
à dire que quand tu te regardes là dans
le miroir tu trouves pas belle et c'est
une addiction en fait c'est une drogue
dure en fait ça
quelque chose
j'ai fait un filtre Shrek
je suis pas assez vert
non mais et donc là comment tu trouves
très banal très banal très bien est-ce
que tu as décroché plus de contrats dans
le mannequinat depuis que tu as fait
cette opération ah oui oui
parce que c'est vrai que pour les photos
pour les défilés c'est différent et ça
change pas mal de choses vraiment
pourquoi le coup
rouler sur les défis non mais c'est vrai
que la posture ça change quelque chose
ça change quelque chose je sais pas je
crois que j'avais envoyé une photo avant
je sais pas si on l'a ou pas alors tu
l'as donné à la Régie
[Rires]
donc ça c'était toi avant non ça c'est
maintenant
et on n'a pas avant
oui ça c'était avant d'accord
mais là j'ai retiré avec un produit qui
s'appelle
leur bouche c'est la mode de l'enlever
maintenant
que la mode est en train de passer elle
vienne et on le retire ce produit
c'est que elle connaît sa maladie la
qualifier elle a mis un mot là-dessus
elle est dysmorphophobe et d'où vient la
doucement vos phobies c'est ça qu'il
faut savoir ça vient dès l'enfance le
manque de confiance en soi et le manque
d'amour si on dit à nos enfants et nos
petits-enfants qu'on les aime et qu'on
leur dit tous les jours ils sont beaux
on n'aura pas ce genre de problème sur
un plateau je vais pas avoir ce problème
avec mes enfants alors non mais Eden
Eden juste
aujourd'hui est-ce que tu es heureuse
alors ça dépend comment définit le
bonheur et c'est vrai que
pas vraiment ça pourrait être mieux tu
as toujours envie de plus éternel
insatisfaite tes cheveux c'est les vrais
cheveux
[Rires]
est-ce que les hommes le font parce que
moi j'ai toujours rêvé d'être un bon
coup donc j'ai eu peur
à 20h45
voilà c'est comme ça c'était une grosse
aujourd'hui c'est ça voilà l'écoutez pas
oui
le même pourcentage que les femmes
disent morphophobes c'est un problème de
société c'est un problème de
communication mais comme je l'ai dit
c'est un premier temps psychologique au
départ il vaut mieux envoyer voir un
psychologue que cette course en avant et
elle n'a pas répondu à ce que vous êtes
heureuse et c'est se pose la question
qu'est-ce que les hommes
je pense que les femmes en souffrent
plus parce que je pense que vous-même
vous devez le savoir vous opérer plus de
femmes que d'hommes
on attend plus des choses est-ce que
est-ce que vous êtes critique par
rapport aux autres également
c'est-à-dire qu'on voyait quelqu'un vous
nettoie lui
il faudrait qu'elle fasse ça non pas du
tout
je suis pas dans le jugement par rapport
aux autres c'est vraiment par rapport à
moi c'est vraiment quelque chose de je
suis constamment en introspection en
fait mais les autres je les juge pas
j'ai pas ce jugement vers les autres une
question un peu privée vous pouvez ne
pas répondre vous savez que souvent on
se trouve beau ou belle dans le regard
de la personne qui vous aime est-ce que
vous avez jamais quelqu'un enfin
quelqu'un avec vous qui vous a dit
qu'elle vous trouvez belle comme ça ou
beau comme ça alors on le dit souvent
mais pas quelqu'un qui vous avez
suffisamment confiance si
en ce moment j'ai quelqu'un
qui me le dis très souvent
[Rires]
elle a recul
très sensible vous dégagez tous les
jours
tous les jours
[Applaudissements]
et l'autre à côté qui va chialer pour
rien
que ça existe
un mot je vais pas vous disiez que vous
étiez très influencé influencé est-ce
que vous discutez avec vos parents
est-ce qu'il y a des gens qui sont
autour de vous avec lesquels vous
consultez vraiment pourquoi tu rigoles
toi j'ai pas du tout des mouchoirs
[Rires]
de la vie des gens c'est elle elle-même
non c'est important d'avoir un
environnement aussi
tu parles à ton miroir
parce que moi
que les gens
[Rires]
[Musique]
ça ça commence à être accepté oui tout à
fait
signer chirurgien de la main le lit de
ciné tu vas revenir nous voir pour ça je
veux convaincre que tu viennes que pour
ça pour qu'on en parle viens de sortir
très important ce qui est important
c'est de comprendre que quand on touche
au corps de quelqu'un on s'adresse au
très fond de son âme elle s'est fait
dans le bon sens ça peut apporter
beaucoup de choses si c'est fait de
façon maladroite et qu'on a pas analysé
la psychologie de la personne ça peut
être un drame pour le restant de sa vie
c'est pour ça que c'est pas une
chirurgie du corps c'est une chirurgie
de l'âme et c'est pour ça que vraiment
il faut avant de prendre la décision
faites très attention est-ce que tu as
des tu as tu regrettes un truc toi que
tu as refait
je regrette les seins tu regardes les
seins
mais pas le coup pourquoi le coup non
bah tu crois tu les aurais parce que je
les ai détruit
tu les as fait avec quel âge quand tu as
fait
pourquoi tu les as refait parce que je
voulais je voulais être ce modèle de
perfection en fait de la fille
[Musique]
en fait j'ai pas envie de
propager des mauvaises informations mais
je sais pas comment expliquer je voulais
être une sorte de modèle de perfection
de la fille fine avec des poitrine etc
enfin comme les ce qu'on imagine d'une
poubelle ce qui n'est pas la réalité
évidemment mais voilà c'est ce que je
voulais être et finalement je regrette
en tout cas je trouve qu'elle a un
discours
et franchement ça peut avoir valeur
d'exemple pour beaucoup de femmes
j'imagine donc c'est super que vous
témoignez avec là et que vous disiez que
vous avez merci vous le regrettez
consultez un psychologue pour tout ça
est-ce que vous avez été un peu suivi
par un psychologue dans ce trajet
[Musique]
parce que je considère que c'est pas
c'est ça pourrit la vie secondaire
je le considère qu'il y a d'autres
choses qui sont plus graves dans ma vie
que ça merci à tous merci en tout cas
merci Eden et merci c'est neona merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]